Little,
we've relaxed.
How did you ever do any fine?
I did kickboxing and how many tournaments I was,
uh,
I was pretty good at taekwondo.
I won a bunch of state championships and won a few national tournaments and you
know,
you wanted to get physical in another human being and do this stuff,
you know,
you can't be in right frame of mind and want to do this stuff.
Got To realize that I was this stuff and not in the right frame of mind and half
dealing with fear drives you insane.
Deal with that.
Drives people insane.
I was insane during my career.
Yes.
Madly and stain from fear.
Yeah.
Obviously I never went through anything like the level that you went through,
but for these full contact taekwondo fights,
I was always scared and uh,
but I was scared before that I was bullied.
I moved around a lot.
I was a little kid,
I was never very big.
And we moved from New Jersey to San Francisco when I was seven,
from San Francisco to Florida when I was 11,
Florida to Boston when I was 14 or 13.
So it's just always moving to new schools,
always deal with new kids.
And I wasn't big and I didn't know how to fight and I got picked on and I didn't
like it.
So I said,
I wanna,
I wanna figure out how to fight.
And so I started getting into martial arts and I just became obsessed with it.
I did it every day I start teaching.
I was teaching at Boston University.
I was teaching a taekwondo course when I was 19 I was competing from the time I
was 15 I just threw myself into it.
It's all I did every day I worked at the school.
I was there every day.
I had the keys.
I closed up,
I opened up where I am because of you,
because you hearing about you when you were running in the morning,
when you knew that everybody else was asleep,
that gave you an edge.
I go there in the middle of the night and open up and work out.
I just wanted to just have an edge,
you know,
and I've listened to what you said and I said,
that's a great way to have an edge.
I became obsessed with it,
but there was no future in it.
And then what happened was I went from taekwondo to kickboxing and when I
started kickboxing,
I started getting fucked up.
Do's are beating the shit out of me because I was realizing like,
I can't keep people at the same distance anymore cause I didn't know how to use
my hands properly.
I knew how to throw some punches a little bit from taekwondo,
but it's not nearly as sophisticated as boxing or kickboxing.
And so then I started kickboxing training and then I started realizing like,
there's no future in this.
Like,
what am I doing?
I'm just getting my brains beat in,
you know,
and um,
hard sparring to the spark was rough.
It was Boston style.
Put the gloves on,
beat the shit out of each other,
figure it out as you go along.
Ain't going shit
out as you go along.
So a lot of headaches and you know,
but it was,
um,
it was hard for me to,
to shut that,
that part of me off the part of me that just wanted to conquer the part of me
just wanting to win all the time to figure out a way to be more intense,
more driven,
more focused.
But when I did stop fighting,
it was a huge relief.
Like the relief part was worth the extra anxiety that I got.
It was worth it just for the relief of not,
not thinking about fighting all the time,
not thinking about when's the next tournament,
when's the next event?
When's the next thing I'm doing?
It was just down in FPT.
Wait,
well,
for you,
it had to be way crazier because not only is it the weight,
it's the heavyweight championship of the world.
I always wanted to make my mentor happy.
Yeah.